you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right well I'm really excited to
talk to you guys today about SHINee in
production but by way of introduction
I'm going to take a little diversion and
take a look at an example app that I've
been working on and we're gonna use it
to kind of illustrate some of the
principles and tools we're gonna talk
about today this is not the example app
that'd be a little weird I want to talk
about cloud our project org or if you
look in the cranberry juicer it's called
zero - cloud this is a cran mirror that
you may or may not know is run by our
studio and it's hosted on Amazon AWS so
it's pretty fast from anywhere in the
world but the thing that makes this cran
mirror interesting is that the download
logs are freely available to download
thanks to Hadley this is what the data
looks like just as a simple CSV file
that you can download and it tells you
every individual package that is
downloaded from our servers and an
anonymized IP address so lots of people
have done really interesting things with
this data and what I was interested in
is I just had this hunch every
public-facing website that I've ever set
up that got a significant amount of
traffic always had just a few IP
addresses that would act crazy
just download way too much of whatever
it was that we're offering not in like a
greedy way but in a totally like WTF way
right as you will see in a moment and I
was curious does this happen on our cran
mirror as well certainly it's a very
very popular service so I wrote this
application called cran Wales and I'll
give you a look here Oh
so this application is loading right now
it has two parameters that I want to
focus on on the top left you can pick a
date that you're interested in and then
the top and downloaders so in this case
by default that shows the top six
downloaders the six most active IP
addresses on the right here you can see
there's some summaries about how much
total traffic there was there's three
terabytes of data downloaded on the
fourteenth and however many files were
downloaded and for all those IP
addresses that we anonymize there were
69 thousand unique IP addresses at the
bottom here there is a plot of the
hourly activity for downloads and you
can see that it kind of ebbs and flows
during the day and that highlighted
portion at the bottom that is the
fraction of the downloads that the top
six downloaders are responsible for
70,000 downloaders and six of them are
doing that and depending on the day that
you look at it can it can vary quite
widely
the second tab will let us look at these
whales are calling them whales the top
the top downloaders so you can see here
these are the top six and the height of
the bar represents the number of
downloads that they made so powerful
argali these names are randomized
obviously powerful argali downloaded as
much as the next five people put
together but a zealous rabbit is kind of
a distant second here
the next tab will show those same six
downloaders or you know we can change
that number we can look at you know say
nine if we want to but now we're looking
at their their downloads over time so
for each hour how many downloads do they
make and zealous rabbit was pretty
steady throughout the day we're a sticky
chinchilla sticky chinchilla I haven't
seen these names are different every day
so sticky chinchilla it just had kind of
a burst in the middle of the day and
finally maybe the most interesting view
is we have a detailed view where
we can actually look at the individual
downloads of each of those users so this
is where I go you know what the hell is
going on here zealous rabbit downloaded
eight packages 72,000 times right it's
probably a Python script gone wrong 33
point 4 gigabytes downloaded
please don't tweet that we're a sticky
chinchilla looks like maybe they
downloaded all of cran 13 thousand
packages maybe they they downloaded the
current version credit and then they
said oh let's go back and get some more
I'm not sure what what happened there
and then you have other ones that are
I'm just guessing here again I haven't
seen these I probably should have looked
before I came up here what is this I I
don't know I just so really weird stuff
happening strange things are afoot on
cran and I'm if you have any ideas if
you're running one of these you know
scripts that are that are hammering us
well number one maybe stop but also I
would like to know what's going on so
why am I talking about this why am i
showing this fun little example app it's
just an example but there are things
about this example that feel a lot like
production shiny apps so it's it's a
useful stand-in number one this kind of
app is very natural to build in shiny
right kind of down the middle of what
shiny is good for your visualizing data
that is kind of like in a tidy format
super easy to build number two a lot of
production apps have data that is
updated over time often on a predictable
schedule and that's the case here
because the cran logs are dumped once a
day at number three there's significant
computation happening when I first
brought up that application it took
maybe eight or ten seconds to load if
it's loading hundreds of megabytes of
CSV data and then doing lots of grouping
and filtering to do all the counting of
individual downloaders and mostly
aggregated data is
being shown here we're talking about you
know millions of rows of data and we are
we are doing various grouping and
counting to show you know simpler plots
and that's the case also with most
production apps you're looking at
summaries of lots of large amounts of
data ok so before we go any further
let's talk about what production even
means I mean we throw around this word a
lot right and I defined production here
as their software environments that are
used and relied on by real users with
real consequences if things go wrong
right so real users not developers and
testers that you know or understand if
something goes down we were talking
about people who really need your stuff
to work and there are real stakes and
real consequences if things go down so
the the sort of antonym or some not
production environments would be proof
of concepts prototypes sandboxes these
are places where you expect things to go
wrong and in some cases like testing and
staging you kind of want things to go
wrong that is not the case with
production nobody's having a good day if
you find bugs and or have outages on
production so I'm using the word
software environments what does that
even mean
well it really means the network
hardware and software and your code all
of that together when you make a
deployment of a shiny app so this is
just one example of what a production
environment might look like you've got
our studio konnekt in the middle running
your shiny application that could be
shiny server instead but you have
Ingenix which is just a web server
sitting in front if you like some people
do that and this particular shiny app is
running on connect and it's connecting
to an Oracle database and a spark
cluster say so that all that together if
that's being accessed by real users that
is your production environment that
whole thing is your production
environment and what we generally do if
you if you're following best practices
is you have an identical set up for
staging you want it to match as closely
as possible to what you're running in
production so you duplicate that entire
stack so that when you are using staging
your
doing kind of like a dress rehearsal and
you want to find all the bugs and work
them out in dress rehearsal before it's
show time okay so that's what I mean by
production environment when we're
running code in production when we're
running production environments we have
several goals the the first goal is to
keep it up we want to keep our
production applications up and running
number two we want to keep them safe the
data may be private the functionality
might be privileged and the code might
be proprietary we want to keep all that
safe from unauthorized access now that
that may not be the case for you maybe
you're dealing with all open data and
and your code is open source but you
still don't want your server to get
hacked for example so we want to keep it
safe number three we want to keep it
correct we want our applications to be
relatively free of bugs we want them to
give answers that are correct so we want
to be sure that we can verify that and
finally we want to keep it snappy when
you're working individually with our on
your own laptop the the peripheral
performance might be a little less
important but when you put an
application into production you are
probably going to have multiple people
simultaneously using your code which
means performance is a much bigger
concern than it normally is so we want
to make sure that our applications run
fast enough for the traffic that we
expect to get and have the ability to to
scale if we need to now a question that
I have heard many times in the last few
years is can shiny be used for
production and my answers why do you
keep asking me that
of course yeah so for years now yes you
can use shiny in production people have
been using / - I mean production
including our studio and many many of
our customers yes it has always been
possible to use shiny in production that
being said we've worked really hard on
the shiny team and elsewhere in our
studio to make the answer in 2019 more
than possible we're trying to make it
really easy
to run shiny apps in production and I
feel like that bar has been achieved
personally that being said I feel like
it wouldn't be in our studio keynote if
we didn't kind of tell you about the
limitations and the challenges to our
own software and in the case of shiny
and production there are really three
categories of challenges there are
cultural organizational and technical
challenges if you want to put shiny apps
into production so talking about
cultural challenges first shiny apps are
developed by our users well I certainly
hope so our users by and large don't
come from a software engineering
background I mean some of us do some of
us don't and if you don't come from that
background if you don't come from a
background of deploying production
software you may not even realize that
you are dealing with the production
situation you may not think about the
fact that people are going to be relying
on this code to be running day after day
and and even if you do know what the
stakes are if you realize what the
stakes are you may not know what the
best practices are for writing
production and applications and deploy
deploying them excuse me and even if you
do know what those best practices are
often people don't anticipate or budget
for the amount of time and effort it
takes to productionize a and and follow
those best practices if it only takes
you three weeks to create a shiny app
and you're getting ready to deploy it
and then now you realize that there's
three more weeks of work to to do the
appropriate automated testing to do
performance and scale testing to think
about security and do those kinds of
reviews it can be really tempting to
just cut the corner and just push out to
production especially if nobody's
standing there kind of looking over your
shoulder and we have definitely seen
people do that and sometimes they pay
the price and finally our users by and
large I think as a community we're not a
culture that prioritizes runtime
efficiency as highly as other
communities like the other extreme would
be like
see community we're generally more
interested in expressing ourselves
quickly iterating easily having
expressive api's and while runtime
efficiency is important it is not the
most important and that can be a
detriment when we start talking about
production applications so those are all
cultural challenges that we that we face
there are also organizational challenges
if you're working with a department with
a organization that has IT and upper
management they can be skeptical of
deploying shiney in production I hear
this all the time from people that the
data scientists want to build shiny apps
and deploy them widely but then IT and
management stands in the way now IT
departments just sort of inherently
their their incentives drive them
towards conservatism and I actually
think that's appropriate I worked an IT
as my first job so I have some sympathy
here they're probably going to be
skeptical at first of data scientists
creating production applications I mean
it's not this is not something that
they're used to and there's definitely
gonna be a little bit of a credibility
gap here and of course IT and upper
management they're always gonna be
skeptical of technologies they haven't
heard of and a couple of years ago
lots of IT departments that we talked to
didn't know what our was much less shiny
that's changed a lot now I think way
more of the conversations we have now
people come to us knowing about aren't
shiny but it's it's definitely something
that's still to be overcome in some
organizations and elsewhere in the
organization if there's an engineering
department a software engineering
department they may not be on your side
right this is something that they're
used to doing and now data scientists
are coming in and saying that they want
to do these things too and they may be
particularly biased against are just
having heard that it's a DSL for
statistics not a real programming
language which is one of my pet peeves
when people say that about our I think
that's it's sort of the opposite of the
truth so those are organizational
challenges that you may have to deal
with if you're deploying shiny and
production
and finally there are technical
challenges and these are my favorite
kinds of challenges because they're the
ones that I can do something about for
you now SHINee dramatically lowers the
effort involved in creating a web app I
hope that's not a controversial
statement we've made it very easy but
what we haven't done is made it any
easier to do the other things that are
involved besides creating your app that
you still have to do before going to
production we haven't made it
particularly easy to test shiny apps we
haven't made it particularly easy to
load tests shiny apps and we haven't
made it particularly easy to profile and
deploy shiny apps until relatively
recently and finally our can be slow and
it is single threaded meaning that in
our process can only do one thing at any
given moment it has to finish whatever
it's doing before it can do something
else so the good news about these
challenges is that we can and have done
something about the effort involved in
doing testing and profiling and
deployment which I'll talk about in a
moment and about the slowness in 90 plus
percent of the cases that I've seen ours
not the problem and we'll talk about
that as well so the rest of this talk
I'm going to be focusing on the actual
tools and software that we've been
working on to help make it easier to do
shiny and production and by the way I
probably should have said this upfront
if you are coming from a setting where
you are not building shiny apps for
production that does not mean that these
things will not apply to you even if
you're not putting apps up that people
are going to access from from all over
or whatever if you care about your app
being correct and staying correct if you
care about performance these tools are
still going to be relevant for you a
bunch of these tools I'm going to not
talk about and then other ones I'm going
to focus on so our studio konnekt you're
gonna hear about plenty this week but it
is our way of serving shiny with
push-button deployment it's an
incredible product we're investing a lot
in it shiny test is an automated UI
testing framework for shiny we did a
Winston Chang did a talk on this at last
year's our studio conf and you can
download that video and there's
documentation here as well that is now
on cran which
not last year I I was planning to talk
about that in my talk but I had to cut
it for time what I am definitely going
to talk about today a shiny load test
which is load testing for shiny which is
more exciting than it sounds
Prof is is not new but it is a profiler
for our and I think it's so important
that I want to emphasize it again today
so I'll be doing some demos there to
plot caching is a new feature that we've
released in a shiny one point two which
came out I think in December and we'll
talk about that in a moment as well as a
way of speeding up plots and one last
thing that I will not be talking about
today is acing which is sort of a last
resort technique when your shiny
applications have inherently slow
portions and I did a talk about that
last year at our studio Kampf again
there's a video available and there's a
very very detailed website at our studio
at HUD that IO slash promises unlike
every other piece of software I've ever
written I am asking you if you are
interested in async to read the
documentation in order I have numbered
the articles to kind of emphasize that
if you go out of order nothing is going
to make sense so async is hard that's
why it's the last resort but if you need
it you really need it and I encourage
you to us to study carefully so we'll be
just focusing on these three areas today
shiny load test profits and plot cashing
now we're going to look at these three
tools through the lens of cran Wales
cran Wales was pretty slow and I'm just
picking some random numbers here to set
a target for us just to give a for
instance so let's just say we want to
support 100 concurrent users for this
application which would probably be
equivalent to an average app at a
relatively large organization and then
again just picking numbers let's just
say we want to support we want to
support this on one dedicated server
with a 16 core CPU in a lot of cases
you'd be running multiple servers just
for redundancy if nothing else but in
this case just to keep it simple let's
say 100 users 16 core CPU so it'd be
great if each of our our processes could
support between 10 and
concurrent users although we'll
definitely if it's more great but let's
just start with 20 as a test and we'll
see what happens so our overall
high-level view of how we're going to
test the performance of this app is
we're gonna start with by using shiny
load tests to see if this application is
already fast enough if it's not fast
enough we'll use profetas to see what is
wrong with it what's making it slow and
then the real work begins of optimizing
and figuring out how do we make that
slow part not slow anymore the first and
most common weight I think that people
should do it is to move the work out of
shiny don't do the work when a user is
sitting there waiting do the work ahead
of time and especially don't do the same
work for every user that's extremely
wasteful I see almost nobody doing this
on their first try almost everybody just
I said I have CSV day I've got gigs of
CSV data I'm gonna load it up into my
shiny app whenever someone connects why
is this app slow so that's the reason
number 2 if you can make the code faster
there are things that you should avoid
in are like you know mutating data
frames in for loops you should avoid
text connections you should avoid using
the apply function to iterate over data
frames sometimes you can find way way
faster ways of doing those things by
vectorizing or using deploy or things
like that
number 3 sometimes you can cache we're
going to talk about that in a moment and
then if you really can't do those other
three things then you turn to async
which which is a whole nother area of
discussion and once you've done all that
then you repeat then now you go back to
shiny low test and see if it's fast
enough and it was fast enough then
you're done so we'll start by talking
about shiny low tests what shiny low
test does is it generates large amounts
of realistic but synthetic traffic to
your application and it monitors how
long it takes that traffic to run and
then we can analyze the latency so step
one is you have to have your app running
somewhere so you can run it locally or
you can run it
studio konnekt or a shiny server number
two you use shiny low tests and a
browser to record what an average user
would do just whatever you think is
representative so click on whatever
inputs you think I usually click on take
as much time to think as you think an
average user is gonna take to think and
once you've done that recording you can
playback that recording with some level
of concurrency so instead of one user
taking those actions you can have as
many of users as you want doing those
actions simultaneously and then finally
we'll take the results of that step 3
playback and we're gonna analyze them in
shiny load tests we have a built-in
reporting feature which I'll show you or
it's just the data frame of events so
you can do your own analysis if you like
so this is what that actually looks like
to do the run your shiny app we just
call run app like normal in this case
you know port 6 104 and then we launch
shiny low tests double colon record
session in a separate our process and
just point it at wherever your shiny app
is running so that URL could be on
connect it could be on Chinese server
Pro or it could be local now that we
have this recording recording that log
say is where it goes we use kind of a
sub command of a shiny low test called
shiny cannon and you give it this
recording and you give it a URL to pound
on and then you tell it how many
simultaneous workers and how long do you
want to run this test for in this case
20 workers for 5 minutes and then it
prints out a lot of log stuff as it goes
to work when it's finished then you go
back to our you load shiny load test and
you call load underscore runs to load
the data that gets your data frame that
you can then pass to shiny load test
report and when that runs it gives you
something like this so it gives you a
graphical but static HTML file that
gives you some indication of how long
it's taking these sessions to succeed in
this particular case what we're seeing
is really really bad performance at N
equals 20 we are in really bad shape so
what you're looking at here is each row
of this plot is a single simulated
worker a single simulated person and the
x-axis is time the red blocks represent
the time it's taking the home page to
load and then the blue blocks each
represent a reactive operation so you
changed a tab or you clicked on an input
you caused some kind of plot or
something to be generated and that's how
long they had to wait and the spaces
between the blue boxes are the users
think time where they're just looking at
the screen so you probably can't see the
x-axis which maybe is a good thing
because that last value is 250 seconds
yeah so we are talking about something
that in an ideal situation would take 45
seconds or maybe 40 seconds when N
equals 1 and when we get to N equals 20
it's taking you know 5-6 minutes to
complete so completely unacceptable it's
this application is way too slow to
support 20 users so what do we do well
we could just throw more our processes
at it right that's always an option and
if we run out of processes on a server
we can throw more servers at it and you
know you left but at some point that is
the answer right I mean Google doesn't
run on one machine it runs on thousands
of machines so we do always have the
option of horizontal scaling but you
know what fun would that be so let's
just make it fast
so the next step and a step that
everybody skips is to use a profiler
when your app is slow use a profiler
when you're our code is slow in general
use a profiler ok do not guess your
intuition stinks I don't even know you
but it stinks
I promise you and it's so easy to to use
profits all you have to do is go to our
studio and at the top here there's a
profile menu start profiling run your
app wait patiently
I swear time moves slower when you're up
here okay something interesting happened
stop profiling and that will generate a
very intricate visualization of what was
happening during that time that we were
waiting okay so that's all you have to
do I have in advanced prepared profile I
don't know if you can see this I'm not
going to get too far into how to use
profits the documentation is very good
but let me just say once you learn how
to read these graphs the answers are
right there in front of you it is so
easy there's no reason to guess what the
time is being spent on and what this
visualization tells us in this case is
that it's taking six point three seconds
to read the CSV file alone just the
parsing six point three seconds
way too long when we're calculating our
first input our first output which is
all underscore our it's taking 620
milliseconds just filtering and
aggregating the data and that's
filtering and aggregating that's they're
going to be the same for every user who
accesses that day of data and then the
plotting just for that one plot is
taking 1/3 of a second so that's those
are all pretty big numbers when you're
trying to put Apps into production for
you know a lot of users so as I said
before the most important optimization
that you should be thinking of as a
shiny author is to move your work to
happen outside of shiny do work ahead of
time if performance matters do it ahead
of time it's really tempting to load
that raw data in but you're gonna pay
the price performance wise so ahead of
time do as much filtering and
summarizing as you can and then when you
save your
instead of saving it as CSV save it as
feather files if it is important for you
to be able to read it quickly feather is
incredibly quick to to load data it's a
little bit slower I think than CSV if
you're writing but for reading which is
what we care about here it is it's the
best if your data source changes over
time then you're not just gonna be doing
this once right you're not going to be
the one sitting down and just like
running these filtering summarizing and
then saving to feather on your machine
you need it to happen on a schedule if
that's you then you can use our studio
connect with scheduled our markdown
reports that is a really excellent
solution that has lots of benefits that
I don't have time to get into now if you
don't have connect or you know you're
using open source shiny server you can
also do something yourself with a UNIX
utility cron for example but anyway you
execute scheduled tasks this is a way to
do it and by the way this this sort of
approach of pre processing your data for
downstream applications you may know it
by its acronym ETL extract transform
load and lots of organizations have
entire departments devoted to this
function so if that's you then maybe
someone can do this for you what I've
done is I've modified cran whales to use
this approach and the repo for cran
whales is our studio slash cran whales
and I've made a branch called ETL that
does some of the processing ahead of
time so if this is our original
performance with the original version
this is what it looks like after just
that one change right so our overall
time to completion has gone from a max
of 250 and an average that's somewhere
definitely north of 200 down to i don't
know 60 seconds something like that so a
really big difference the size of each
individual block has not only gotten
smaller but also gotten more consistent
so we're seeing more predictable more
understandable user wait times and an
overall we're looking a tremendous
amount better so I'm gonna pause for a
second and bring up those are just
screenshots but I'm going to bring up
this is the actual shiny low test
webpage that was generated so this is
that screen that we've been looking at
this is the visualization we've been
looking at and we can flip back and
forth between these sink and ETL
versions of the app and this view shows
all of the sessions that were run sort
of arranged tip to tip but this actually
all happened over five minutes so this
view shows those sessions running where
the x-axis is actual elapsed wall time
so you can see here that these 20
sessions did not really finish very many
sorry these 20 simulated users did not
finish very many sessions maybe each one
finished three sessions or something
like that if we switch to the ETL branch
a lot more sessions are getting complete
so a lot more work was able to be done
because it was so much faster there's
also this event waterfall view on the
left hand side we're basically looking
at the recording script that we
generated when we kind of simulated
being a user that first line you
probably can't read it says get home
page and then there are many lines maybe
a couple dozen lines of retrieving
JavaScript and CSS which should be
really fast and it is and then
everything from that kind of hump where
they all go to the write down those are
all reactive operations so that's the
actual work of the application being
done and again the x-axis here is time
so in an ideal situation if our app is
super fast these lines would drop
straight down they drop straight to the
ground instead what we're seeing is as
soon as they kind of finished the
loading of JavaScript and CSS these
lines kick way out to the right meaning
that the user is waiting a long time to
proceed from one step to the next if we
switch to the ETL branch
these lines are much straighter so you
can see not only are they straighter but
they're sort of smoother and more
consistent so each of the individual
sessions are behaving pretty much the
same way I won't get too far into the
the other options
available here but there but there are a
bunch of other things you can look at
this one shows the the amount of latency
for each homepage request and the top
facet here is the original version and
then down here is the ETL version so you
can see a huge difference and then the
same thing for WebSocket traffic which
really means reactive computations so
reactive computations took a really long
time here and then for the new improved
version way better so let's just
summarize how we did so ETL clearly much
faster what we learned from that report
was that the median session duration has
dropped from 210 seconds to about 50
seconds so a huge difference and the
maximum wait time was unspeakable now
less than 10 seconds so 10 seconds is
good but it's not amazing right so can
we do better we can start our second
round of profits and just for time
reasons I'm not going to show you the
profits this time but what it basically
shows us is that almost all the time you
can see is in ggplot plotting at this
point several hundred milliseconds per
plot so in order to make this faster we
now have to turn our attention to
optimizing plots and that is a
particularly difficult thing to do for
various reasons what we've done with
SHINee 1.2 is introduced this feature
called plot caching and if you're not
familiar with the concept of caching
what it means is if you have an
operation that is going to be performed
multiple times with exactly the same
results maybe don't execute it every
time execute it the first time save the
result and in future times you recognize
that oh somebody's looking for the same
result and you serve up your already
cached result so we're gonna do exactly
this with plots
it requires shiney 1.2 so if you want to
play with this you'll need to install
from cran now plot caching is not for
every shiny application so there are
some criteria you need to meet before
you can decide that this is going to
work for you number one you have to have
slow plots right if your plots are super
fast
and cashing them is not going to make a
huge difference but we do have slow
plots there several hundred milliseconds
each and they have to those plots have
to be a significant fraction of the
overall slowness of your app I mean if
you're taking seven seconds to load CSV
data then you know speeding up to
several hundred milliseconds of your
plot you can do it but it's not gonna
have a dramatic impact but for us we are
highly optimized everywhere else we're
just looking at plots remaining third
and probably most important because
caching only speeds things up if
somebody asks for a plot a second and
third and fourth time you have you have
to have the kind of app work that's
going to be likely to happen if
everybody's looking at individualized or
random data or data that updates every
second
then caching may not help you but for us
anyone who's looking at a given day is
looking at the same data so check there
as well so we have an excellent
candidate for plot caching now we've
made this as simple as we possibly can
and I'm really proud of the work that
was done here by Winston Chang this is
what a regular plot looks like and this
is what it looks like using the new
caching feature so number one we change
the render plot to render cached plot
and number two it's a little bit
trickier to explain but we have to tell
SHINee a little bit about what are the
variables that matter when it comes to
forming this plot in this particular
case we're plotting diamonds we're gonna
make a scatter plot and we are going to
let the user decide what variable to use
to set the color so one user may select
clarity
another one may select cut and we need
to make sure that we don't miss match
those two as being equivalent so if a
user asks for a plot by clarity we don't
want to serve them a previously saved
version that was based on cut so what
cache key expert does is it gives you
the shiny author the opportunity to tell
shiny when you cache these are the
variables that matter now we are
actually doing some things under the
hood like if you are on a mobile device
we'll catch a different version if
you're on a Retina screen versus not
well cache it
conversion will actually change it based
on the width of your browser but but
these are the part that you need to care
about is cache key expert but this is
all you need to do so I did this seven
times for my shiny app this is the ETL
version that we have looked at already
and once we have made those caching
changes and run the same test again yeah
holy [ __ ] is right there's nothing left
there's nothing like that that you can
see the the little rectangles are still
there and I can see them on my screen
but I guess they're not not showing up
very well there but the the ending point
is somewhere around maybe 20 seconds so
this is running significantly faster
than the original one was with no load
at all which is not really that
surprising but at this point 20
concurrent users what are we even
talking about right so we are way way
beyond that so again our original
ridiculous version this is ETL and with
caching it's that's hardly anything to
see and I think it's most clear when you
look at the the latency here that bottom
one I mean they're they're essentially
is no latency just for fun I I don't I
don't have the results here actually
maybe I do I ran it this morning with a
hundred concurrent users just to see
what would happen if we could do all
hundred concurrent users that we want to
support in one process and
and it is now visible like the the
latency is visible now that we've
quintuple the traffic but it is may be
borderline acceptable I'd run maybe two
processes with this with this branch
okay so that kind of summarizes these
these tools shiny low tests prof is and
plot cashing I will make the URL for
these slides available so if you want to
see any of these other URLs you can you
can see it so when I do Q&A I'll be
showing that so with these tools our
goal is to make it much easier to run
shiny apps in production but these
challenges remain cultural and
organizational challenges that probably
be a subject for a pretty good talk but
it will not be this talk and finally I
want to leave you with with this thought
that deploy deploying production apps I
hope you've gotten the sense that it's a
real skill and it takes experience to do
this well so you know be humble when
you're deploying Production apps and
especially you know the people in IT
that are hanging you and and you know
raising a skeptical eyebrow they're not
the enemy they might they might be the
enemy but but oftentimes they're not the
enemy they have your best interests in
mind and they are trying to protect you
from from pitfalls that many many
companies and organizations and
programmers before you have stumbled
into so if you have people in IT and
engineering that you can treat as
partners you're a huge step ahead and
definitely lean on those resources if
they're available to you I do want to
give credit to the wonderful members of
the shiney team past and present and
other members of our studio team who
have helped with all the software that
demonstrated today the shiny team I
couldn't ask for a better team we're
really excited about the work that we've
done in the last couple years and we're
really really excited about the stuff
that we're doing this year so thank you
[Music]
so you can download this slide deck at
this URL Oh actually if this URL doesn't
work just take off that shiny in
production I don't remember if I set the
slug right but speaker deck comm / hn5
and I also wanted to call out a Kelly
O'Brien has started working on a shiny
in production book Sean lot and Kelly
O'Brien did an awesome workshop the last
couple days on shiny and production and
they've taken some of their materials
and they're they're condensing it into a
book so that's where the
work-in-progress is located great and
with that I will take seven minutes of
questions if you've been to an Austria
comp before you'll know we'll have these
throwable microphones and you will also
know that I am very poor at throttling
so we have a team who will run around
and I'll kind of spot them so joke and
you can look what you're asking
please remember that a question should
be a single sentence that ends in a
question mark
so any questions
[Applause]
talking about the plot caching is there
a way to do that in a distributed
environment to pass it between multiple
servers is there a way to pass oh that
the yes well is so the question is if
you have multiple servers running the
same shiney how can they share the same
cache is that what we're saying yes okay
great yes I haven't gone into any detail
about where the the cached plots are
being stored but it is an extensible
mechanism that has that gives you a lot
of control so you have several ways to
go
the simplest way for it for sort of
casual uses you can just cash to the
file system and you could also cache to
a shared file system but what I would
recommend instead is there are examples
in the documentation for using Redis
which is sort of what all the big boys
use to do this kind of caching big boys
and girls used to do this kind of
caching and and you can pretty easily
plug that in as the backend for for pot
caching before I take the next question
I forgot to point out that this slide
deck actually has an appendix of best
practices by no means complete these are
just like the random thoughts from my
head about some of the different things
that you might want to do in r2 to have
your apps be good production house so
you mentioned preparing data in a
scheduler markdown document I'm
wondering how where you put the files
especially on a clustered or connect yes
great question so currently with connect
what you would do is you would set up a
folder somewhere I can't I don't know
where you are I'm looking in this
general direction so if I'm not making
eye contact oh hi yes with connect today
what you would do is you would create a
folder on disk that both applications
have permissions to access and and then
you would basically just configure that
path into your application in the future
what we would really like is to have a
or sort of first-class representation of
shared data in connect so the the name
we've been using for that feature it's
called data pools so unless that changes
if you ever see the data pools feature
arrive for connect that's what that's
talking about and that would give us you
know once we know more about what your
intent is by you know having this
first-class feature of a data pool then
we can do things like permission the
data pool for you instead of you having
to manage those things yourself but yes
for today you would you could go to a
database you could go to a shared file
system location but really like you're
you're sort of on your own but but there
are lots of ways to do
great question yeah yeah in academia a
lot of credit result is based on and
publishing in journals for publishing
shiny apps so you have a favorite
Journal or will you go a different route
for even credits credit to people making
with shiny apps you should ask anyone
else at our studio besides me hi I
barely graduated with a bachelor's so
when I hear the word academia I freeze
up a little bit I have no idea I really
I don't know anything about journals
people ask me like I want a site shiny
how should i site shiny and I don't even
understand what that question means all
right
I say excited however you want and they
don't seem to like that answer but I
don't I don't know whatever I honestly
don't know so yeah is there anything
built or being built to help with
integration testing automated
integration testing oh you make me
regret that I cut that whole section
from my look at all these hidden slides
that I have created well I can't
shiny test is the answer to that the
shiny test hit cran sometime late last
year and what it does is well let me
preface this by saying you should be
unit testing your are code that you are
calling from your shiny app but unit
testing doesn't help
with testing the app as a whole so we
call that integration testing shiny test
is specifically designed to help you do
that
it is designed not only to do
integration testing but to make it so
easy that you might actually do it so
what it does is similar to shiny load
test you record a session of yourself
using the app and you have a special UI
on the side of your app that we inject
that lets you say take a snapshot here
take a snapshot here as you do various
things and then in the future as your
code changes or as you know your
software configuration changes as you
upgrade you know packages from the tidy
verse you can run that test again and
then it will automatically give you a
visual view of the differences so sort
of like a friendly like not unlike get
the get support in our studio so it will
give you both sort of a textual
representation of the data that's
different and also can I show this no I
can't show you ahead and slide ok well
let me just what it'll also do is give
you the ability to examine in several
different ways the visual snapshot of
the before and after your changes
so yeah shiny test is where you want to
go for that one more question
yeah real fast I just wondering if um
you all are thinking about providing
caching for other kinds of rendered
outputs yes leaflet data tables things
like that it is as if I seated these
questions
yes caching it's almost backwards that
we started with clock caching the
question is like are there oh you guys
heard the question there's mics
it was almost backwards plot caching is
by far the hardest thing to cache in
shiny so we decided to start there
because that's the thing that we don't
want users to try to do themselves no no
offense but I just I don't want you to
have to go through that effort to do it
correctly other things are a little bit
easier you can kind of build the caching
yourself if you're sophisticated with
shiny but we were so happy with the way
render cache plot turned out that what
we are investigating is there's gonna be
cache plot and then there's gonna be
everything else cache so there won't be
like a render cached text or a render
cached
you know print everything else will get
a generic like you'll just type your
render text or whatever into a cache
directive and then everything will kind
of go from there that being said we're
having some kind of fierce internal
debates about what that API should look
like how magic it is how automatic that
cache key expert should be so until we
kind of sort that out it's a little bit
TBD when when that feature will land so
it's not currently in a schedule for a
release but it's sort of the next
natural step but definitely if you are
interested in that feel free to file an
issue and upload it and that really
helps us with our prioritizing so thanks
so much
[Applause]
[Music]